well let's start yes yeah how's a good
story we'll get into it each other while
still energy dude I missed you because I
know you were dealing with a 27
interviews a day in Vegas radio room
yeah and then it bothered me I be honest
with you that show time didn't have your
point of view on this whole thing it's
okay it is what it is it is what it is
they might have taken care of it was
great like all week I worked you know
the weigh-ins all that stuff and then
like probably the night before I found
out they decided not to use me on the
broadcast because they wanted more
boxing focused yeah no because that's
what they do
yeah you know I I mean in all honesty of
course is like dang like that there's
thought that was upset I get it you know
what they have their crew that they work
with but it is what it is I'm gonna do
more stuff to Showtime down their own
yeah you know okay over there's some big
fights come up so good good good I get
it man and I you know I had a great
company to work for anyway great company
but you know again I'm trying to bring
you know I'm not a journalist I like to
have fun I can't write super pass on my
opinion like you'll die at this so the
day before the weigh-ins they have they
call it talent meetings and don't have
talent means with Conor and Floyd yeah
and they only let six people in the room
and so I didn't think I was part of it
because and then I'm gone and my guy
Brian from Short times like yo you're in
your names on the list where the
fighters meetings I'm like why tonight
before I'd have dinner every night with
Showtime and there talk about the
fighter meetings and how it's like the
best thing to do and all the stuff and
then go yeah I remember last year or the
last fight for take that one guy out he
didn't recognize I guess because the way
it works just like a big business table
and then there's you know the Showtime
team on this side just like six of us
with mics on then there's Floyd his
promoter and two guys that's it Connor
decided to skip it okay then it's only
Floyd's team I figured I'd do Connors
but not Floyd's
so in Floyd's team they told me last
fight Floyd didn't recognize one of the
guys like get up get out get out super
embarrassing the guy like turn red and
like hobbled out so I'm sitting like I
want everything to kick me out it comes
here he comes in and you know it's like
it's
I'll gray al Bernstein everyone know
who's who Holly who's hilt I'm the big
dog yeah Espinoza the head of Showtime
Floyd sits down and everyone's asked her
questions so sick I mean it's so serious
you'd cut a knife through it so serious
I'm like I gotta mix this up and then I
don't feel right this isn't my vibe you
know I got yeah it'll be a little
trouble all access team that I'm like
I'm just gonna shoot my shot here so
it's like um it's like you know waiting
to go like double-dutch like yo Mike um
she can jump into this [ __ ] and go and
so they're asking questions and I might
Boyd do you know we don't know much
about Connors boxing you know you have
no really material to use it to base it
off of besides that Polly sparring tape
he's like that that ain't real that I
don't give a [ __ ] about that that's just
that's not boxing I was dirty I don't
know like that looked more like him I
mean I don't I don't care about all that
he goes on this rant about how
everyone's so focused on social media
and I thought it was brilliant that was
my take away from this whole experience
you know just how much of a businessman
and how brilliant yes yes so he's
talking about how everyone's so focused
on social media and saying that he's not
ready for this fight not taking
seriously why because I don't post when
I run every day since fighters announce
at 3:00 in the morning
mmm I run 15 miles I don't post it for
you guys in social media and you guys
don't think I'm ready you know he's like
what do you think's going on here he
goes everyone's so focused on social
media so it's back in serious Jim Gray
has a Tom Brady FaceTime in so you know
with Tom Brady and he's like Tom wood
I'm up this time and get up there and
see I'm like what is going on right now
so we're sitting there again it gets
real serious and then it's almost time
to go and I'm like God we got like one
or two questions and I don't feel right
about that I take advantage of this and
so then some guy goes you know usually
have a pretty orchestrated entourage
when you guys walk out you know you've
had all these guys walk out with you
before do you know who's gonna do it and
him and Justin Bieber have had a phone
yeah
so I out of turn go not the Biebs like
that at the side of my mouth well we
know it's not the beads and literally
you could have heard a pin drop in that
room
Floyd's talking to Jim Gray dragging
sunglasses on he goes towards me goes
damn man
we'll try try q+ up here my gun for sure
getting kicked ideas damn why you got to
bring up that man what's going on and I
was like I'm just saying and I started
laughing at ease I'm like come on man
I'll just come on baby you and Bieber I
don't think that he's not walking out
with the belt in him why you know like
we know that means kind of broke a smile
please glasses back that's that's not
scary and then I was like oh I'm for
sure gonna take heat when we get out of
there so it's all you're like dang have
a good day flip it leaving we're in the
back wall and then I don't think they're
taken outside of themselves when
everybody has to be on their best
behavior it's like in school in the
library I think what is going you need
so to shake [ __ ] up not be hot the boobs
he's he's a brilliant guy man I watched
the fight with Special Forces guys and
professional boxers the testosterone it
was a Frank Willis house and it was it
was the the testosterone in that room I
would vet this is not saying that I'm
tough I was definitely the the biggest
[ __ ] in the room yeah isn't saying much
but we were power bottoms I was a power
bottom in that room and it was very
interesting dude I want to pick up my
tickets because I was in work show time
they gave me great seats and I tried all
access credential pass so I could let
her go to the floor literally go
wherever wow there's this pretty
probably saw Piven oh yeah yeah Sarah me
when me and Piven talked I saw a bunch
of people up there so I could get
literally go wherever locker rooms
anywhere and then I got my taking I like
the tickets my tickets were good but
7,500 each
Wow so the arena's packed except for the
top Bowl because they [ __ ] up and out
priced the common fan normal Irish fan
can't go to that no so you know when
usually that Horry is oh all that those
guys aren't there cuz those guys can't
afford five grand or what's not and they
didn't you stuff up they took out the
middleman do you have to go direct em
Jim you get to take it so you there's no
there's no no deals no clothes it was it
was a bad move but that place was packed
well now is impact but I think they few
listen to Floyd and if it's true
the direct the pay-per-view servers went
down then with California and Florida so
how smart is Floyd he's in the back the
yo-yo the servers are down for the paper
because so many people trying buy it it
was cool I'm gonna wait this is while
he's warmer up he was I'm gonna wait
till they figure this stuff out and then
I'll come out so he waited till they got
it back up then went back out again I
told you it's gonna break paper you know
everything they say it also broke it did
gate numbers it's gonna break all the
records everything you said in private
and public came true I think yeah I
don't yeah and I'm gonna give you my my
assessment well first of all I think
both of them came out complete winners
and I agree one of the things that I
think that I really appreciate about
about Conor and I said this is I think
that the guy is in many ways a heroic
figure he's heroic because he he puts
everything on the line if you think
about what he did the risk he took to
get in there yeah I know he's confident
but he still boxing the best there is
he leaves oh and oh and he's oh no he
could have looked so stupid he could
have gotten knocked out right away they
were it was a risk regardless what
anybody says that was my biggest fear
yes and and so here's this guy who comes
in and I mean the way he was talking I
couldn't believe his his self-confidence
oh look part of it maybe he's talking
himself into it it doesn't matter the
bottom line is the guy is inspiring his
example is just inspiring now Floyd
Mayweather a true master obvious and
came out looking incredible too and
here's why if Floyd had wanted to fight
Conor the way he thought Manny Pacquiao
I'm sure he could have made Conor miss
I'm sure he could have done what he
usually does which is way back and take
those shots maybe a mask two years ago I
think he I think his ability to box is
still undiminished
however this guy says okay I'm going to
I said I'm going to come forward I'm
gonna come forward with my weight I
think primarily on his front foot left
the first few rounds he did it either
way either way he changed his style and
first of all I think Connor did very
well
Floyd might have gotten hit
in this fight you could make the
argument that he has in his letter
landed more punches than manufacture
well that's for sure I'll said that's
also part of that's part of the reason
for that is because he fought Conner
differently you can say that but
remember Connors Owen oh right so we're
gonna uh he the only reason he had more
punches because he it was a different
style well he can't do so you can paint
any narrative you want to so you're with
a pro boxing crowd right yes oh ah no
he's just one rounds because it's the
way Floyd was fighting well let's look
at that
Floyd can't fight him the way fight me
impact yeah Floyd can't sit in this
traditional Philly cover up shelf
because you can't find a southpaw like
that and sit back and eat shots oh you
can't get against it oh you need a
straight laughing so you can't fight you
have to adapt can't use this no did you
set up for a straight laugh all day
can't sit against the ropes and do that
so he's gonna change his style not what
point do you give Conor credit you have
to get in crab you know you can pay any
near if you want so that pro boxing
crowd you're with or the people on first
take whatever it's cuz the weight fluid
fought okay that's fine don't give up
the fact and still won yes four rounds
on the judge card they even gave him out
yes
I don't know jail so and I had $100,000
bat and he went to you it was literally
gonna give me my money I told no no I
was just doing it yeah I don't want your
money man that's cool who's legit gonna
pay my money I love it yeah that's that
says a lot about you ya know and so so
what I'm saying is that you either way I
think Conner proved to be an outstanding
boxer here uh what do you avoid said he
said he said he was surprised right as
angry they asked Floyd what were you
most surprised i what caught you
off-guard most and he goes I'll see you
when there's power I felt bigger
punchers yeah which was that's fair cuz
it you know heel and heel and a flush
upper Ken still kept coming forward he
goes how good of a boxer he was he goes
I wanted to turn it on earlier and I
could it because of his boxing there you
go
and he put the gloves on Floyd's face
you can say whatever you want but nobody
wants to have somebody jab you in the
face
catch you with uppercuts Conner did his
dad in the corner ghost you can turn on
whenever you want let's go turn on
whenever you want I was like I want to
was tough and when I talked to Floyd or
cuz I said yeah well I talk to Paulie in
the back
he goes do I'm kind of glad those first
like five rounds went like that cuz when
I sparred Conor like I couldn't get [ __ ]
the early rounds like it's difficult man
Wow
like those early rounds it hits you know
his style did the pawn like you just you
don't know what to do with it yeah that
boxer actually fight with his hands so
far out because they say that's a
liability you can catch a left hook or
whatever it is but he fought with his
hand way out right which was very
unorthodox you don't see that with
boxers very rarely oh yeah but either
way I think what it proved was that
Conor is a way better boxer then then in
what the boxing community a hundred
percent not the moment and he's
surprised he surprised a lot of people
with it you know I think more box in the
mainstream but like anyone I was like
what you what I tell you you me watch
this fight you're lucky - oh Jesus
dude he give that route to Donner sing
around Jesus who'd he give the round to
cause you said it in private - it's
because he it was why because he has an
under-construction ball and he can buy
he can box and floran hit the thing that
makes Floyd so special is he doesn't
risk a lot until he knows it's certain
yes shield Floyd psyche in a rush at
Conor McGregor and he's gonna wait to
feel things out and if Connor can box
he's gonna win some rounds
I know Connor can Bob yes Stan and this
is what I this is what I always say and
Conor even said in the press conference
egos the guy changed his strategy up
three times that's what makes him a
champion and I think it's the same thing
with Andre Ward guys like Floyd
Mayweather they may take ten rounds to
beat you but they're gonna beat you
because their ability to download what
you're doing eventually is gonna come
because their IQ so high their ability
to adapt yes but they also they always
stick to the game plan no matter what
happens you might catch them you might
come out south Paul traditional whatever
this distance it they stick to the game
plan never deviate from the plan there's
always a plan right and the plan was let
him let him punch himself out in the
beginning and then will capitalize they
drunk which he does he's done it in a
lot of fights my thing is this it the
reason I think Floyd Mayweather is such
a great champion it's not taking
anything away from Conor at all but in
boxing the reason he's such a great
champion is I believe that if Connor
fights Floyd a hundred times Floyd finds
a way because he's such a great boxer to
beat him 100 times
I agree unless Connor were to land some
lucky puncher yeah but yeah that's fine
it takes nothing away from Connor no I
think Connor showed X surprised the [ __ ]
out of everybody including the boxing
community I told you I was them back
with Amir Khan
Berto oh you are Terence Crawford
they're like Jesus your boy can box I'm
Joey are you yeah in that aisle sans
pedigree guys our pedigree I was a
little sad after I was a little sad I
thought Connor would even done better
mmm I thought I was gonna do even better
I expect even more I don't know he did
great I'm proud of him but I don't
thought he knew better so I was like I
was like I was in a fen I was like
really yet man I thought he went more
rounds that like what how do I think a
lot around I went off a great champion I
thought I just thought he would because
it's so awkward they're like man that
the he goes he can box I'm like yeah I'm
and I I agreed with the stoppage one of
the things I saw you - yeah because I've
no problem and Freud's over Floyd said
dude he's protecting your future he's
not protecting you right there he's
protecting your future and you could
have happen to happen the only way
Connor was gonna win a seal and that big
punch in those first four rounds yeah
once that was over him saw his tired
there's floors and keep pouring it on
yeah so he taken out lived a final day
we got it we saw this experiment we're
done no need for the damage
get out of there I actually got up out
of my seat in the eighth round once I
saw it I got up to that to be backstage
so I got up and watched it from the side
inside do you think that because of my
buddy Tony Blair I wrote an article
about this I thought was very
interesting about how you your training
informs so much of sort of your central
nervous system learns certain things and
when you've been training for 25 minutes
at there at round 8 I think was was
probably the 25 minute mark
do you think that that played a factor
in because if you look at the timing
no that's I mean that's a stretch I get
what he's saying but they're like a Nate
Diaz Nick Diaz could go 25 minutes
there's a lot of guys seem good okay go
go pee on there definitely can they can
like you give him five rounds keep going
Conor we've never seen him you know like
the five rounds we did see him go he was
good gas against a bigger guy so cardio
is not his if there's if there's a list
of strengths for Conor McGregor that's
not in the top he said it he said he's
not party oh god he
said in the press conference because
there's a patch and I love this about I
love this about getting good at
something he said there's a patch in a
fight for me where I get fatigued and I
got to figure it out he got to work
yeah what is a second it just happens I
do you worry like how my unit loose and
then something kicks in where I don't
know that second you get your second
wind your body it's a mental thing in a
physical thing you know you're gonna
have that you get through it you know
for him he even said in training he goes
you know I get to the seventh round
coming right corner how many we got like
you got five more like holy [ __ ] man you
know it's just it's just different you
know the his yeah his is Stan MA his
endurance hasn't always been his biggest
asset so for this fight
that was the x-factor we didn't know we
saw that so this what happened so we've
done I'm in the back I'm Kate side cuz
Showtime when we do this thing so I'm
Kate side see Connor I just film I'm
proud of him right keep going
busy night walk in the back and that's
when I'm talking to America everyone's
there but a rod JLo I saw gigolos ass in
person fantastic I have to stare like a
creep you know I have to get David off
doesn't TV show where he cuz there's no
reason to 48 your woman should look that
good dude it's ridicu she walked by I'm
like you know what I'm gonna be that
creep I'm gonna pull a Bryan Callen
stare of course you'd saw I lost you
right on its your right as an American
man you know what she said what love
your boots we'll talk about that so I
could I had a question for you hold on
come on
so I'm talking to Aamir Khan Terence
Crawford Berto we're on the back and I'm
with the Showtime guys they're in suits
so I'm in my suit like hey we got to get
you back am i cool I'm walking down the
back and I see Nate Diaz now there's no
UFC really there there's no USC
representing anything in my head I go oh
[ __ ] same fraternity he's by himself
I guess hey what's up I heard before him
do interviews all officers pushed me
stuff my kind of talking sh about Conner
talking to like that I saw him and my
first instinct was to go to him and go
this is what you should be doing they
have a press conference they're getting
an interview one I would do I know a few
things about marketing I'm not the best
in the world I look very good at it
just came off for my help cuz a lot of
guys asked me for help and I usually
don't do it what we gonna say to him I
was gonna so hey Conor Ozzie lost but I
don't think you celebrate his failure I
think you celebrate the fact that he won
rounds against the best of all time and
it shows how good of a striker you are
cuz you outbox Conor you know Botkin so
what you should sell is Conor one rounds
against Floyd I'm gonna be able to
finish Conor better than Floyd did and
faster hmm and then give you a list of
reasons that's my plan of action
so I heard going there to tell him that
I'll to my right and people Showtime
like hey we got to go icon horn so I see
my by himself on his phone and I go up
with your brother we did good tonight
man hopefully get that next huge fight
biggest pay-per-view of all time in the
UFC being cool you know me I'm course
plus you like him yeah I like him he
looks at me goes oh hell no you must
feel like a [ __ ] dumbass and I'm kind
of caught off I'm like excuse me he's
like are you talking all that [ __ ] about
Conor I'm like whoa whoa whoa stop sup
all that [ __ ] I worked for a Showtime
man I'm here to represent him in me what
all that [ __ ] what you said came true
you weren't and then and then I go he
won rounds bro can you hailing anyone
round he goes that's just cuz you're no
box and Floyd game that rounds I went
however you think about it he still won
rounds against the greatest of all time
now he's getting heated and I'm like
what are you doing like I'm like what is
going on I was literally coming over to
help you I did not I should not have
stopped and he keeps talking and then he
goes he hits me and he's in my face
living hits me knows that you just don't
know boxing you don't know [ __ ] about
boxing yeah I know it's crazy I'm
working for Showtime doing more stuff
for Showtime - so I'll see you man and
he still keeps talking [ __ ] they start
talking about my career this I knew he's
running out of material he's like going
nice fight with her laughs skeeball why
I'm like oh I'm like what what what
that's it and they keep talking I can
understand them and I think this was the
trigger I turn on go bro use your words
I can't understand a [ __ ] you're saying
it you know he has like here's that list
when it's you know this speech isn't
exactly the best I didn't mean to offend
them I just go I could understand what
he's saying I know bro use your words
think that was a trigger then he flips
me off starts
doing this I'm like what are you doing
right now I was so embarrassed I'm
around like a sewing bit yeah it's all
business me I'm like what is going on
right now and then I tell them like whoa
whoa I have zero problem with you like
that caught me off left feeling how is
she's with you what are you doing right
now
hmm so I go to walk away and he just
keeps talking so I do you think that
maybe what set him off was and it's just
it's it's just a question because I'm
wondering maybe what really set him off
was those stupid [ __ ] boots um boys
JLo love yes those are the ones with the
buck you talk about the JLo three that
maybe Nate just naturally saw the boots
it became blood red mad the way I do
that might you know what you don't say
I'm just saying they need you maybe your
boots took him out of himself and said I
go bro I'm gonna tail it shoot skinny
jeans and some goddamn Gucci shoes what
I'm not getting a fight yeah I'm a dad
yeah I'm 34 I'm a dad right
I'm also oh this is no win for me I
thought a hundred pound heavier weight
cotton you got 155 100 pounds UFC has no
wind love Nate though cuz Nate would
fight it would fight a UFC heavyweight
nanofied alright that see I knew people
go that I go I love that look you
there's a place in time for sure you
think you're pointing your gun at the
wrong guy like you you had such an
opportunity to get people excited about
you versus Connor three and you have
this mag this magnitude of a fight you
have all these people around there's a
million interviews we could have set you
up on and you chose a point your gun at
Mia I'm not I had nothing to do we do
your boots have a lot to do with it but
I know I get it beat I get it I'm just
saying like he had such um treat and now
the headlines I mean him yes you're
talking [ __ ] to a podcaster comedian
Showtime guy I'm not fighting yeah if I
was your shirt's [ __ ] now you bring our
retirement it's like yeah you wouldn't
fight him for it
Nate Diaz and brandy shop ten million
dollars I just yeah I was like wow man
you [ __ ]
I like hopefully he was there to hype
that fight this did not do what do you
think he might have been drunk no okay
no
one of his boys I would say I had a
conversation and he was just like man I
don't he does it's not that he dislikes
you you dislike him I think you know
he's in that fight environment and he he
just feels like if if you're Pro Connor
you're against him I'm like bro I'll
tell you this if Nate Diaz was in that
fight I would have wrote just as hard
for him yeah I would have
I would I would have wrote justice it
wasn't a percent I love Connor I love
what he's about I think he's a glitch in
the matrix and I love people who are
outliers if Nate Diaz in that fight I
would have smoked same regards 100% on
my death you know so that's a bummer and
maybe you know fighters as we've talked
about fighters are super sensitive about
any slight to them they need enough he
should be the only anything is power to
get that fight you don't get that fight
man this is not a good story yeah yeah
yeah he needs to he needs to get that
fight that's the next fight for him
and I think Connor might have alluded to
it he did yeah so that that's then you
got to say that you called all of this
you you said and and Andre Ward said the
same things that you said in the first
four rounds possibly three maybe four
it's going to be awkward for Floyd he's
gonna have to figure him out and I think
Connors gonna win some rounds know
everything you said came true yeah it's
exactly what it was but Connor did I
would suggest kind of did better than
even probably you thought he'd not
though no no I thought I thought not me
I thought I thought you'd lay in a big
punch and wobbled him a little bit I
thought if there was a K or TKO come
from Connor I was wrong on that I said
you know conjugal win rounds if there's
a stoppage via Conor feet and the
otherwise goes the distance with Floyd
but yeah it's good I'm glad it's over
I'm gonna be honest I'm so glad at I
know you are tired of talking that fight
I'm glad it's over I what's funny about
me is because of the pot guys I have
many people asking my point of view on
the fight and there's you know well
there dude there's no one better there's
no one better than me at that sort of
cherry picking all the bits of
information I hear because I'm a [ __ ]
black hole for information and I put it
together in a nice little pot a clay pot
and I present it and by the way when I
present it it's you know I'm doing a
little boxing while I'm doing it you
know I'm doing the Philly shelter you
know I'm doing South a we're eight do
you want to see Connor respond
in boxing I don't mean either no I
didn't Paulo you know I love you man I
just I don't see the kind of box anymore
I think he's proving it and I want to
see him get back in MMA and I'll tell
you something else about Conor
I want to see him maybe fight one more
two more times
Oh Thea fight one more time and then I
want to see him sail off in the sunset
and be a great American slash
international figure I think he's
awesome and and I think he'll have a I
really think he'll have a career in
Hollywood and I never say that about a
lot of athletes because it's a very hard
jump but he's such a character and you
know what he is he like you said he's
not out there he's a liar he's a thing
of beauty he really is he's a thing of
beauty
and he and I you know he did it coming
from you know it's the great American
story even though he's Irish it's a
beautiful thing man and gracious [ __ ]
guy is gracious victory and defeat
humble I don't get it like a feet did
you see Snoop Dogg he works for the UFC
now you know Snoop Dogg has like his own
broadcast announcer oh my god it's so
bad I don't know if your current event
and it's it was so embarrassing he was
like and smack right when Connor was
like yeah [ __ ] you Connor you [ __ ]
schmuck
all these us it's so bad that's a guy
who might not understand fighting
doesn't watch fighting maybe I don't
know it's weird you know maybe I do hi
he works for the UFC he commentates fly
that's why it's the ad wait a noop doggy
dog well don't say soon dog you know the
dog doggy dog I'm high 50 yeah you
definitely are don't ever say it like
this go on
Snoopy doggy dog errs our dog says
whatever he does something with your I
favor for the The Contender sisters
yeah that's very strange to see I don't
get when people celebrating someone
else's demise but also Sodom I am ice
dam I like when oh you you mean first of
all your he made a hundred million
dollars and you did well your fifty your
extensions are back here you're 50 and
you have a show with Martha Stewart
why are you dick riding Floyd
Mayweather's you did
thing you've done not you've made you
make good music he did a long time ago
you made some great hits here forever
ever ago
other than that three years you've given
us nothing right what are you doing why
are you hating on someone's demise why
why what are you doing I don't
understand that I don't get that semen
like Connor who doesn't like Connor and
and the way he was so gracious and the
way he gave Lloyd props and what a
warrior he is try getting into something
you like he took on the best there is in
a different sport and looked great I
don't care what anybody says it took a
lot of balls the only one who took a
hell this weekend everyone else every
everyone else won snoop take it out for
that yeah I'll be surprised they keep on
the broadcast well it's not even that
serious but whatever um
though I did do in Vegas the day of the
fight rapport of course I see rap and
all the stuff best won't pipe the [ __ ]
down
oh and here's bro you keep hanging on
three on three but could please be a
guest like God and I'm like you know I
can't do that I'm not working Showtime
today I'm gonna go down there go down
and get my tickets
I'm freakin floor side and it's like you
know it's safcord it looks like a pickup
game but you know just like people it's
not that full whatever but I I see all
the UFC guys I see Dana I mean they had
a quick chat it was all good oh really
yeah well because I'm sitting on the
floor and I see him come in and he like
I see him looking at me like look off
and like this is stupid it's a big day
for us man yeah so I go right to him I
go I put my hand out yo good luck today
man I know it's a big day for you and
UFC I'm nervous man he shook my hands
like I'm nervous - I've never been so
nervous I was like he's gonna do well
though don't don't worry yeah how's it
yeah it was conversation go back to my
seat another very emotional guy no need
to build for this right yeah with an ax
so um collect my seed and you know Allen
Iverson I wasn't enough sure when I was
working but Allen I've seen Kevlar is
cool to see Allen Iverson really cool
he's tiny
he's like my size right 6 feet maybe six
foot meme rap rap goes every P look at
him maybe six foot with shoes on it's so
clean that's the MVP so somebody said
the hardest guy the best football player
come out of Virginia
Michael that candy goes well actually no
that's not sure soon as it was Allen
Iverson like coach Riley he just
couldn't you couldn't tackle the coach
said that yeah he was the best guy I've
ever seen on from see you so he was
Charles Woodsen's brother that was my
coach and I'll see seen Charles Berlitz
and his brother he seen on everyone and
he said the best high school player he's
ever recruited was Allen Iverson and I
don't know everything I didn't know you
know me I don't watch basketball
donating and but you know how much I
appreciate athleticism and I remember
watching Allen Iverson and I watched him
run a ball down and I watched him dunk
and I watched how easy he left the floor
it was like he was on cables you should
jump and I go did you see how he dumped
that little guy and and Jimmy Burke goes
that's Allen Iverson you [ __ ]
anything is it he doesn't know Allen
Iverson he doesn't know about
athleticism and he said that ladies shut
that place down like everyone's just oh
really yeah everyone's gravitating
toward them so anyways I'm sitting I'm
next to the players bench I'm a huge
psyched Kenyon Martin they're not really
taking of that fear so I can't take you
serious
I saw the Fox people are old Fox but
they were great name I'm saying what's
up Aaron was cool
I'm not it was great not seeing what's
up everyone joy Taylor all yeah it's all
good healthy so are not dying so I'm
sitting down next the players bench and
they're playing I'm like I can't get
other fast enough like ah first quarter
all right and then I'm like rap howling
yeah this he's like all night you know
I'm probably good for another hour and
half my cool man you gonna go over there
and work though yeah my cool man so you
just be over there he's like yeah for
Wommack I sinned I'm just waiting for
turns back in this see ya I was just
born made a beat I was born made a
b-line
I won ate sushi by myself never tell you
what he was saying to the kids rap was
coaching my 14 year old yeah nephew you
guys are [ __ ] yeah I'm not waking up for
this [ __ ] anymore
Lisa he's holding as he's clutching his
chest yeah but you use a ring size with
the the owner the the head dad for
barstool sports rap was the fast to
together the other both great Bobby Lee
yesterday I watch I was I was with him
at the Comedy Store and he goes I want
to come on the podcast with rap
Rappaport oh my god I would be fun yeah
it's about Rob Rob does give me on rogue
and won't you give me rodeos but I do it
for [ __ ] three hours I'm due an hour
I'm leaving I'm like well you ain't
getting on this like what
but you
you enroll you can get together so
rapidly and Rogin is like I don't what
are you talking about right and if it's
not fighting Rogan has no [ __ ] idea
no idea just there's something I can
tell you gonna mix that ain't the only
guy who knows less about baseball
basketball football then than me it's
Joe Rogan III make Joe Rogan I make yeah
I mean I look like you when I'm talking
to Joe about sports
he's never been into sports I don't know
I don't [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ]
about the Olympics I like fighting yeah
Reb just doesn't know me now it's funny
seeing that and he's just going off of
the oh my god Colin a little weekend we
then I have to walk because the there's
like some issues all the cars leaking
from the stadium to our hotel there's
like soap act like it's pregnant me to
our wait for you guys get out of here
just packed but poorly-designed t-mobile
they said mots we get in and out in
there so Morrow's like we could just
walk you know take about 20 minutes and
I'm like that's it 20 was I did the
other day Brendan will just walk and so
it's moral me and Pat Miletich walking
in our suits house Pat's neck it took
just about an hour and a half yeah and
my feet were hurting so bad Pat was
pissed cuz why the [ __ ] did I follow you
Mauro he's so upset I was like awkward
you so upset
we're cutting through laughs yeah yeah
let's go man is rough it was a nightmare
but we and you were in your awesome
boots though dude my pinkie was
suffering super suffering yeah yeah well
you deserve that right in fact I
remember I text you I said how those
boots working at you go knocking a lot
got some blisters but I'm gonna keep my
leg pain is beauty pain is beauty that's
what you said dude how us I saw my hero
last night on the VMAs Jared Leto you
did yeah you want to talk about dropping
the ball and you hate em team you know I
love you they dropped the ball because
they were doing like a dedication to the
that Chad the lead singer of astir
Chester yeah Chester bento from Lincoln
Park apart so jared leto who he was on
tour them very good friends with both
the guys commit suicide the guy from
savage Soundgarden yeah Chris Cornell
and Chester
note was on tour of them for years years
and years Jesus knows him very well so
he does this open monologue like
tell them their story is they can now
here is the last time they played on
VMAs - doesn't it like this epic then on
top of Hollywood and Chester's jamming
MTV cuts it's short and goes a
commercial like it just shows ten
seconds cut it short and that but and
then even more awkward JLo goes so now
everyone please get on your feet this is
the last time Chester perform at the
VMAs in Hollywood and it's like this
epic performance and the whole cast
sitting there and Juno goes I have all
night
I will wait - every one of you get on
your goddamn feet and then everyone
stands up Wow then they play the video
that's like Mintos do you have fresh
breath why yeah now it's like oh they
[ __ ] up No yeah like very
inappropriate oh my god now suicide
brought to you by Mentos yeah nose look
like it's emotionally she's like rocking
out you're like oh my god he's such a
talent and it's all bheem do you like
double cheeseburgers are you looking for
- I was like ah no that's like looking
in the Sun like the Sun over the egg
turn the lights I was like ah my eyes
are so bad man Jesus I think just Oh
Katy Perry's whole like monologue and
beginning was so rough it was so rough
like she's what did she talk my choose
from outer space she's like I've been
out of out of orbit for five years let's
go along so he gives her a paper
she's like dress like [ __ ] I don't know
shitty aspect she's the paper she's all
hot gimmick the world's on fire
what'd I miss and then they give her
like one of spinors kids played what
she's like
this is it and I was like oh my god who
wrote this know who wrote this no oh so
rough oh yeah yeah it was so rough hey
Michael Jackson's daughter is a hotline
piece can you bring her up for a second
cuz I I you haven't seen her before
well I looked at her and I and I thought
my show hot in this right now she is now
now she's his biological father no
biological daughter let me see did he
just a question she's so white look sir
it's her mom Presley I know my mom is
door or some other that's why I was
looking I was like mmm
interesting no I'm not mad at her I
don't know she's delicious but I'm
saying
oh hey a half glass no putting his Paris
Hilton's dad it's right a beer oh that's
that's his that's who he had sex with no
so they they just put his sperm in her I
see she's hot don't you stop doing and
don't sit with your hand here fish
that's obnoxious so they put they took
his they took his his jizz that's hard
to prove I'm sorry it's hard to prove do
you think he it's just hard to prove do
you think he hired a super hot Swedish
man because she looks like very Swedish
to me I'm sorry I don't see I'm sorry
can I say this out loud I don't see any
black can you bring up Michael Jackson
ladies younger because I just want to
see if he was black I wanted to see if I
could served him older but that was when
he turned into a small white woman but
I'd like to see before he turned into a
small white woman I'd like to see when
he was a black man if you don't mind I
just like to see if I if this is the
real and I just want to see if both
there's the other kids yeah yeah go
ahead and get him know but before every
literally says yeah go go right there to
the small black child right there that's
right there if you could that will go
over there click on any one for God now
Brennan
that's a black yeah that that's a that's
an African American cute kid a very cute
kid but that I would say that there's
not a lot of Swedish in him nor is there
a lot of but the mom so goddamn why sure
I go back to Pierre Rochon got you I've
seen three wonder whether joy went to
Paris and take a look at her first sack
yeah yeah that's the Sun - yeah those
are super white kids the Sun train that
uh the grace of heaven forever great
yeah so I'm gonna say this I don't think
it was his sperm there I said it
now all due respect and and she still
loves him as her dad and he is her dad
but am I am I being am I being unfair
here I think a little bit
am i yeah I she doesn't look like a
straight-up white girl
she doesn't get cuz she does look a
little exotic yeah and by that you mean
very Swedish yeah she's as white as my
wife so I'm having trouble I don't well
no let's see I'll bring up recent
pictures of Paris Jackson I mean I want
to see her again please yeah yeah now
art the awards right yeah go ahead go
ahead yeah there's a lot of
african-american her she's half
african-american you out of your [ __ ]
mind all due respect it's all good I
don't care though she's pretty she's
beautiful but she's also you think she's
like harms in occasion yeah she's she's
as black as only click on for me too
yeah Jin's navigation skills on silky
blond hair looks very northern European
but listen I'm sure there's some African
in there somewhere but I don't know her
mom is just so dead that that you tell
me that's a you tell me that girl right
there is half half african-american yeah
I got there I'm my eyes I'm sama I'm a
[ __ ] I got skeptical hippo eyes right
now it I don't believe it I just don't
what are you talking about what are we
talking about it is a little strange
yeah she's a cutie though she is
delicious she's 18 sir
oh yeah no I can't call the coalition's
because it's well he said delicious
she's 18 but I couldn't you know in in
some parts of the world I would be
allowed to have her as my child bride
she's just a model yeah she's a model
activating spokesman I guess she went
hard in the paint
yes she's like she went hard in the
paint against the neo-nazi and she's
like now for video of the year it's
always weird when it's always easy to go
hard in the pan against in here Nazis
nobody's ever gonna be like most of us
know neo-nazis in the crowd like hey
come on yeah we're people I know they're
dicks some of them are very nice people
that's all I'm trying to say yeah
or as as Trump said some there were some
very fine people hey Donald both sides
medalist
not say that though can you not play
that do better how about how about did
you see well you didn't see it but you
see the suicide thing No did you watch
the award settle chin I saw we went
Jared Leto's talking about suicide know
when what's his name who's the white kid
rapper logic do you see his performance
suicide you know type in logic MTV
Awards for the video yeah
my boy about it's about suit its it's
really intense hmm miss carrier I would
scroll down to yeah the logic performs
ya know if that's the real business
logic I like that I've heard the song I
don't be alive I just want to die today
you might be able to find it somewhere I
love all that right there right there
chin so it's about suicide and so logic
struggles with depression stuff like the
house Don Cheadle Don she knows awesome
[Music]
because so and then the song the the
Tyler song is the number for the suicide
hotline Oh
suicides so high right now our teens and
here's the heights ever been as a parent
with children man it's the scariest
thing intense
[Music]
[ __ ] I'm talking about they think they
know it I've been praying for somebody
to save me no one shall row I get my
like don't even matter I know it I know
it I know I'm hurt deep down I can't
show it I never had a place to call my
now think it's important song you know
I'm saying like when you listen to the
lyrics are so harsh sure you feel deeply
when you're a teenager man deeply but
and anyone with not even teenagers I
think it's anyone with like depression
suicide I'm so in tanjur I can't even
fathom what so I have some experience
with it from people I've been very it
was rough like they had like suicide
survivors surrounding the stage and
they're just bawling crying sure I gave
the suicide numbers on it's too powerful
[ __ ] yeah yeah it's fair which where
somebody was explaining where escape
seems that kind of escape seems like the
most logical plan because there's no
other alternative yeah you get there
that's what they do so it's a rational
decision and that's where it's it's it's
you know you can imagine how you know
anyway I can imagine but yeah a bit well
what's hard is you know you can't help
the person sometimes like you don't know
so you don't really from my limited
experience with it but I've had it you
don't know how to help the person you
don't know what to say because you're
not a professional
sometimes the person's smarter than you
so so one one example my friend Ashley
he said I want to give you my
Springsteen collection and I said your
whole Springsteen collection he goes
yeah I'm gonna get out of here and I was
I went were you going boys what do you
mean are you going back to England he
goes no I'm gonna get out of here and I
said well why why he started crying he
goes because I'm [ __ ] miserable yes I
mean I I tried to talk him out of it but
he was smarter than me it was Arthur
yeah I didn't know I was 22 oh and I
didn't know he was very smart and he was
a very successful well holy [ __ ] he had
actually a big influence on me because
he gave me a reading list and I read
every book so he was younger so I called
him the next day and he said you know
what my my brothers having twins so I
found another reason to live and then
two weeks later he'd killed him Locke
and I got a call from the woman I work
with and she said
actually actually kill them do it I
think he took pills he never woke up and
it was just this logic thing but [ __ ]
you don't know what to do look up so the
I I don't want to misquote that you know
getting murdered for it
what's the suicide rate yeah the thing
is that the highest has ever been in
certain certain demographics probably
right from 1999 to 2010 the suicide rate
among 30 percent hmm the largest
increases were among men in their 50s
with rates rising nearly 50 percent to
30 per 100 oh yeah why this is my thing
not my thing
but why is it so so higher than ever
I've read a little bit about this you
think it's because just hear me out
because you probably know that's not ask
you is it because we have more access to
see the evil in the world now because
you're cutting he can't say get
stimulant from hey like that if you
realize how bad the world is even if you
have depression like it's easier to find
the only way the only reason I would say
no is because there's also a flipside
that where you can also see what's
really great about the world so but but
from what I have read this is a case in
a lot of the white population for
example because so much of the economy
has changed and there are huge subsets
of the populations that are that have
skill sets that are no longer relevant
to the 21st century economy so there are
huge parts of Safed like sort of swathes
in this country that are not either able
to earn a living or are thing look at
the opiate crisis I think that a lot of
people feel out of step out of place
without anywhere to kind of like you
know latch on that's why people the
fifties commit suicide that's that's the
theory that's that's the theory that
those things that are that are the ones
who are hit the hardest by the jaw cop
ellipse you know the idea that ones that
did prepare for well true manufacturing
jobs are gone construction jobs of God
they don't have the tire in place yeah
so so all of a sudden you don't have
purpose and you don't have relevance and
you know that's where people get afraid
that's where they join groups that's
where they buy guns and build walls is
also easier than ever to find how to do
it now I'm sorry it's also easier to
figure out how to do
now right well yeah although before it's
just um it's pretty mainly I was blown
away by the opiate crisis I was amazed
at how how deep a crisis this horrible
I'm horrible among moms among dads I'm
among everybody to get first thing they
prescribe that's right the escape that
it's literally the most dangerous drug
in the world in your doctor's the first
thing your dr. dozous here you go well
it's also the the synthetic forms of
heroin now they have called what's it
called fentanyl or whatever it's called
fentanyl but no yeah and so you know
these things are so addictive and this
is this amazing play written by a black
woman Lynn Nottage who heads up I think
Yale dramas a literary Department she
want to Pulitzer Prize for a play called
sweat there's a black woman who wrote a
play about basically what it's like to
be a working-class white and black
American when your factory shuts down
it's called sweat on Broadway and I'll
tell you something man it blew me the
[ __ ] away because this black woman gives
a human face to people who voted for
Trump and who are angry and does such a
[ __ ] brilliant job and and it's it's
a heartbreaking play but boy oh boy the
opiate crisis she brings it all around
she brings it all the [ __ ] way around
one kid who's at Spanish is working he
kind of breaks the picket line and he
starts working at this factory because
he wants to make a living and they beat
the [ __ ] out of him and these two kids
go to jail and come back now and have to
make it's [ __ ] a brilliant play but
she kind of she doesn't dismiss this
group of people as being racist or
idiots she as a black woman goes they're
human beings were reacting because
they're afraid they're angry they feel
betrayed they're marginalized so we went
a little dark little dark well why not
why not talk about it because it's real
and people are dealing with it all being
real I'm a switched subject to yeah I've
a love a drink
yeah before I finally found the dream
because I did - I did - I want to hear
what you're saying I like I had one as
like a nightcap last night oh you did
yeah okay cuz I'm gonna can I tell you
what - and I want to hear yours I'm
drinking I'm drinking notorious whiskey
don't be surprised if I start ordering
my Conor McGregor notorious worth well
as soon as sound like really
as soon as it hits the I don't drink
whiskey mmm
I'm whiskey time now what's your drink
Campari soda well we talked about I know
I'm just saying like yeah I bought my
own bottle yeah again and I want to say
that Nate's justified what's wrong with
Campari well because you drink comparsa
you know what's in it and you wear those
boots you know what's in kampala makes
me plaid right know what's in it what no
one knows they do no they don't
somebody knows what's in it now I'm
gonna make a guest Campari xpect hold on
I'm gonna say that Campari might be we
know fruits in it obviously I think it's
a cherry derivative nope all right
there's no sugar might be a pomegranate
derivative sugar in it it's bitters it's
bitter which I love so Campari it's
gonna bring up on the side chin kind and
bring it up but you don't know they say
it's a secret recipe to secret recipe
mmm
really makes me want even more because I
try to taste it like I'm in the
chocolate factory do you know we do art
do you know what you [ __ ] are awesome
I just realized you're a goddamned Andy
you want a dandy as bro daily line no
it's a date or mother Buell we're gonna
load up dandy after that you would use
an ear trumpet and you'd use an umbrella
to keep the Sun off your face if you
could they know just watches yeah think
we got compiled and then when it goes to
ingredient I wish I could bully you I
wish I was a I wish I was Brock Lesnar
so I could just shove you around into a
corner
I'd bully I'd bully you up I want to
bully up right now a mouth is water my
gosh got into that too nice try
you know we haven't talked about Brennan
you know we haven't talked about John
Jones you've been a dick diver but we
have dick diver shirts coming out I
can't wait have you seen those yeah
right they're very good looks like a
certified scholarship we haven't talked
about jobs well Wow real quick though
secret um compiled has always been a
symbol of intrigue and pleasure when it
comes to aperitifs roof the intense
aroma inspiring flavor creates a captive
unique drinking threads my mother drinks
Campari and soda really my mother has
always been a Campari instead of woman
and of course I guess it a chick drink
well the you can part why because you
know it's James Bond's second drink
besides shaking up stirred yeah Campari
and soda jayvon okay
yeah ball I don't know about that you
bought I don't know gang me bond I've
watched all movies me but you're not be
blonde don't say you're pond you make me
mad bra me blondie
don't make me listen bro you're too big
to be bond number one you'd be the worst
line what - babe you [ __ ] here's the
giant guy who's a spy hey where's the
tough guy in the room you'd be the worst
no I'd be awesome dial it down bro I was
the spy the huge American guy chin we
looked up bonds favorite drinks James
Bond it says martini shaken not stirred
Campari soda there's no way there's just
no way martini no no no no hold on hold
on hold on shaken not stirred
James Bond's favor drink right yeah well
we know it's phase you know see see what
else what James Bond and really dirty
love Google even though they fire people
for speaking their mind although it is
combined so crazy also enjoys a fine
Kapoor psycho right now I do not see
that I'm sorry it's you can be seen now
crews in the streets of London in an
Aston Martin with no party Gucci really
fancy - no [ __ ] can't see it I always
wondered from yeah you oh wow do not
change mommy JJ's meat meat homosexual
JJ's my me JJ yeah
that's so fun Oh John John broke my
heart broke your heart yeah I heard it
was maybe a diuretic because he was so
big oh yeah then he had to lose weight
oh yeah took a diuretic that's it no I
well that's what your Romero I think was
pinched for a diary
yeah though those you learn to try
whatever they can I'm off to John Jones
Jane I think you the snake I think
faster disaster it's a why would he make
a mistake he's a smart guy it's naive
and the the thing is we had a whole we
down the big round breakdown
old chemist who's involved with steroid
stuff like that send me an email
breaking down the steroid test pause for
yeah and it has this super half-life
with an hour so it should be not a
system we said this stuff is so hard to
obtain
by prescription you get on the black
market and a lot of time these power
lifters who John's been hanging out with
you know remember all these power laugh
just get from the black market we don't
know where it's come from sometimes they
mix with other stuff and that can be
caught in the trace amount so it's just
a bad bad stick because that's when
power lifters get caught and what it
does has like a two-hour window where
you should be out of your system it
makes you super aggro aggressive like
you want to kill someone you pop it
right before our competition Jesus
Christ that's crazy yeah and and in this
case that name that makes all the sense
in the world that makes for you the
emails brilliant taking steroids do you
know I'm off the John Jones train it is
there any escape to this or is it just
done the greatest fighter we've ever
seen is done it's done I think people
are sick of well I think people are sick
of him letting us down did John's
consistent two things being people up
and knock down and then [ __ ] up
that's always consistent it's okay he's
out it's fair has he said anything
yeah he did remind me how bus so much to
be grateful for
ah look at that guy rolled his eyes
sounds like you around blessed I true
I'm so sweet grip for hey man what what
else is yeah that's like the worst thing
for me to read as a fan
me too of like [ __ ] you well what it's
over so lebretia caught so let's say yes
through your suspension he's 30 29 I
think it's 30 yeah 30 so let's say let's
say he gives a for years for years so
the kids about you're 34 this ship has
sailed
I'm over it it's over I don't understand
I don't understand I guess it I guess
it's too tempting when they say hey it's
got a two hour you don't need it you're
the best in the world what are you doing
or he does need it or since you saw that
he's failed three out of four tests and
does need it yeah so he's not the best
ever
there yeah DC is DC is
dan you want one what worst case
scenario yeah
they go you're right stain supplement
program strip your belt gear back dc-dc
you have to fight this monster again six
months yes piers a third loss that's
problem here's a third would DC do it or
is he done no DC wants to fight you must
fight John again he's he's got he's such
a badass he said that after I mean
before John popped he said he wanted to
fight him again yeah they'd be friends
with him he wants to make sure you know
he can't be friends alone cuz he's gonna
fight him again
they said DC was on vacation Hawaiian
daily yo so uh you think God
good so DC's beat everyone in front of a
set for John Jones everybody in front
I've always said he's the most
impressive fighter to me Daniel Cormier
he's brilliant just can't be just you
know this gives John Joe but it's all
irrelevant cuz we don't know if John was
clean when he's fine we know he wasn't
[ __ ] twice now first time is on cocaine
right which that is an enhancement I'm
gonna help you with tar do I think he
was probably also probably you know look
if he's doing it twice oh yeah that that
that was my thing it's like this isn't
something just take on I'm the best of
all time let me try this real quick no
it's something probably done so bomb
look very very in shape and very amazing
also also you know we always talk about
and I've talked to people who've been
steroid users and athletes and the
biggest problem is when you go off those
drugs you'll normal your body doesn't
produce the testosterone normally that's
take you have to take therapy recovery
sure because you're never that's wrong
will actually plummet so you could have
the testosterone of one guy I know who's
been I'm a longtime steroid user and
when he stopped he said my testosterone
was that of a brownie a young girl
elementary school girl you know I had
none of it it was like 20 but the thing
is think about it and I've never been on
it but I can imagine you're on it you
feel like [ __ ] Hercules sure so you
know what that's like
then you have to go fight normally like
oh my god I'm capable of this yes you're
never gonna feel like you're bats like
you're going there without armor or
something right
it's like driving a car with a
supercharged me take that I care just as
good night priest a query I do the same
race without the supercharger Oh Bob
this is why at 50 people like you out of
your mind get on testosterone um I don't
want to be attached to something like
that I don't I'm sure I would feel
[ __ ] great but I just but you don't
feel that now right no I feel great but
I'd be more muscular I'd probably put on
like 10 pounds and look awesome and be
very happy with myself I never done it
you like to obsessed with I know but the
but hey I don't want to be that guy
dudes I'm just dick diver hey don't say
um don't say like that don't drag up yes
like that don't diver
yes I'm surprised consents you're
obsessed with male bodies don't go and
get injecting your ass once a week and
then just start [ __ ] guys like like
if so it like let's say you I can't quit
find the killer
all right cool and then like a year from
now like bro you have you seen talent
lately he's jacked like 10 [ __ ] dudes
I wouldn't even I wouldn't batten ah
make sense
not a night area you know I'd be doing
the [ __ ] area with shredded family no
I wouldn't don't do that yeah what is in
your mouth why are you because that's
what Jimmy did am i sucking on a
lollipop
why no no no homies are under John
mm-hmm like at least give me something
to suck on a little candy yeah you're
sucking dick no I want to be sucking up
a wine cap no you're sucking Davis's
dick I don't know Davis Davis this new
black friend yeah speaking of sucking
dick chin how's that tinted eight go oh
man
chinder what's going on Ches there's no
time but this week for sure I'll get
everything you're waiting for the right
pictures we had an actress too we had an
expert reach out to us do we talk about
this now we an expert reached out to us
and they're telling him he needs the you
have to I guess he's a professional dick
downer and so he yeah tinder expert so
he's saying this this and this being
flirty what else tips might be
over-the-top almost too
over the top so it's funny yes the
problem is that you're you're being
asked to be somebody you're not
yeah about that because they might
they're probably gonna be super creepy
I'm chin hey [ __ ] kimchi just out of
line
hey girl trying to [ __ ] or what ya know
I've told to be over the top this is a
picture of him in a scarf in a cat
that's his avatar hi my name is chin I
like him small I want to eat peanuts off
your head you [ __ ] shorty he's just
making horrible racist Asian jokes then
we'll find a dog grill it am i right
wait wait wait wait having a talk haha
not be another asian girl all this
preachers mrs. sweet-and-sour sauce
am i right just him in two cats huh see
this puppy hasn't got long live I'm
starving huh oh [ __ ] chinder so tender
nothing's going on a tender yet huh not
yet we got to get this [ __ ] Reuters
browsing the pages until you fro the
right granny and browse bro you just
pick a goddamn picture and get this
thing going
and this week you don't need glamor
shots to shoot this deal we do it with a
high-tech case of procrastination I
agree you're a little scared hey you did
get that dick out of the show cuz right
now your dick is hiding in the shell get
that turtle out that egg roll I'm
walking hey you're a little skin no no
I'm saying your little heads we were we
were in Vegas man I know but all my two
non-stop oh you can get to home let's do
a little roleplay I'm gonna be your date
do I like this we're eating oh hey I'm a
I'm a servant okay great
the servant serve the service you have
slowly yes chin fed up let's very
special North Korean dinners so these
are
yeah well that's Japanese so I'm gonna
ask you but maybe they have Japanese
guys cuz Koreans like to order Japanese
people yeah sorry why is not North Korea
alright but how about Japanese also a
bad Japanese accent it's super offensive
I'm not and how do you know I'm Asian
oh I'm Vietnamese no what do you like
chin I've dated Vietnamese yeah okay but
I'm gonna be a Vietnamese on your dumb
blonde I'm okay I'm good I'm gonna be
I'm gonna be
like I'm gonna be this this la girl do
you know they mean like I think say I
never really usually date Asian do you
know II mean but you're super tall and
also I heard you singing on your tinder
profile and I love talking eyes you
insane so that's sort of what I'm doing
here searching about starving you're
starving fire - thanks for coming
oh my god what would you like to order
my service right here Oh your sir man no
my servants are here no he's big hi
C Mon you up if I'm a giant servant you
[ __ ] up I'm gonna dick your girl down
hey bro you just [ __ ] serve me my
food and shut the [ __ ] there you go hi
um why are you holding that tray because
I have I haven't ordered anything well
no that's a wire it's a romantic thing
he said [ __ ] it's a five-course meal I
don't know he's talking to me in a
really aggressive way and I don't feel
comfortable so don't like his ears
they're making my stomach turn
they look like tortellini and I was
gonna order the tortellini and I don't
want it hor all right and that's true
while that's true I feel it's a little
aggressive right now can you tell him to
stop yeah that's not for me man hey hey
hey hey let's see how chin deals certain
situation okay so come on super strongly
all right get out there swallows gravy
and get home okay first our first
scenario I have a super aggressive horse
super aggressive or go so I have a total
confession to make um Asian guys
especially tall ones are my fetish and I
play with myself and I download big
angry Asian guys when I watch porn so
would you mind I don't know have you
ever put a dog collar on a girl it just
kind of roughed me up no it's a little
weird you know let's take a little
slower I just met you oh my god hello
chin wants to get to know you okay I
guess we can eat if I just know this I'm
gonna be so horny and for dessert she's
you know deep throat that I want that
dong yeah I want that it better be a
dong because when I say dong I want your
dick to be so big it's got an X
why do you keep laughing at me sorry hey
what did be helping out what should you
do if we can comes okay aging horn like
a 10 is it better make them wait like
that what sadder to make them wait uh
now chin fog you make like wait hey bro
you have left this hey why don't you get
out of my country hey neo-nazi oh Jesus
Christ
[ __ ] that make them wait away
gentlemen huh guy hey come Ram it make
them wait lakhs
yeah that's in 10 seconds for the time
it takes you to get your [ __ ] dick
short yeah listen to the man are you out
of your might just this is why you want
a slump-buster you looking for wife each
is both Cheers a little else gent and
deep territory you know what it is chin
this is the first time don't have things
great first time he's been in a ring
right now and that's Tom MacGregor your
girl's Floyd Mayweather bit with tits
this is the first time you've been in
the ring and that's okay so so for guys
who don't have a lot of experience which
maybe you don't or maybe you just feel a
little combination you're little worried
about it little bit you've been out in a
while you been out of the game you got a
man [ __ ] like my friend over here
myself and you know by the time I was 14
I was I was digging it down yeah you
talking about a guy who's probably come
down with chlamydia 4 or 5 or 10 times
you're not an STD you ain't doing [ __ ]
exactly you're not my friend remember
this common bit for [ __ ] she's right
you haven't leaked in your underwear and
had to go to the doctor right away the
you ain't livin you ain't live welcome
to America but here's a truck here's the
wrong to turn Trump so having said all
that what I think a good wit start is to
ask girls questions about themselves man
go ahead ask me some questions so what's
your favorite thing to do I'm out that's
a general question the same jeopardy
okay Bice talking about sort of what you
find mysterious or interesting about the
world do you know any magic to it yeah
girls like psychology and magic so you
know girls like talking about how the
brain works and psychology right in
magic I imagine what do you what do you
find mysteriously magical about this
world that terrible question
you see you kill I mean that treat me
yeah yeah what do you find out stairs
and dark men are ahead while you're at
it
well she has a nice built entire skin
all over above your head you want to
wear it after you've if you have good
skin in your head you said you have a
nice head he's magic
that's not a serial killer that's a
compliment a girl hey yeah I'm Korean
you have a nice head your head looks
good hey your eyes all right yeah
you have deep eye sockets and your skin
all the skin on that covers your body
looks thin I don't want to do this
anymore
you know blueberries having some trouble
yeah we got worked on it yeah hey chin
you gotta make a new job damn profile I
got an idea I swear to God being serious
try doing this just start talking about
how it's awkward and how you don't know
I like that yeah I do like the honest
what's really going super awkward great
just just talk about how this is I got I
got a confession I don't I haven't done
this and I don't even out of talk start
with that I'm serious that's a tough one
no being drunk just it's on I say you're
totally honest just like I am
I don't know I'm doing it I'm so nervous
and it makes you my my boner is my take
to cut through your [ __ ] glass right
now is that too much your might be crazy
but also say why don't we get out of
here
[ __ ] get the road come on and and
paws on deck
go you know I got a dick my dick is it
[ __ ] my dick you know I'm doing it my
dick is it could cut a diamond right you
know what you know what I think you
should do dating in the dark oh then
you're forced to use your words
you can't judge them just based off
looks so bring her home and shut all the
lights off immediately that won't be
creepy I'm so nervous
that's gonna slip these cuffs on and
take the oath just randomly give this
pill super drink yeah here now this is
gonna make you feel I get a little
nervous oh you mind if we just do this
in the dark that's right want a Cosby
tale
don't buy my old sweater here hey for
reals though finger they know they do it
professor you dating in the dark yeah
yeah we do like around the start by
being really honest about how you feel
and I'm like kissing her in the face
no fear in the face man your face is so
hit about God you know what you look
like you can take a punch
can I just get this out I love your
jawline here I suck you mind if I give
it a whirl
laughs I slap it in the faith you box
cuz you should your face looks like one
big bag um the worst advice yeah all the
worst things to say to a woman I mean
for real like start telling her to say
I'm nervous I don't even know what to
say I've never done that is so weird is
that yes thank you I wouldn't know if I
do oh my god I'm so nervous and awkward
you know it's hard to not like somebody
when they're vulnerable
so if you go I I can't believe this like
my stomach's been on the edge [ __ ] right
now I'm wearing diapers so I just let it
go
that's fine I know see I I think being
upfront but you gotta be a little like
show a little [ __ ] just they want a
confident dude - they do you like oh my
I am so nervous I just my [ __ ]
friends put me up too high to cry on the
first it's a good thing to test though
I'll try both both methods hey hey hey
it's probably not gonna go well hey chin
maybe don't they a little bit baby for
you chin chin listen all [ __ ] aside
all [ __ ] aside but I spend the rest
of your life oh thank you hey Jim here's
the thing bro
[ __ ] the dating let's just order your
[ __ ] from Russia and not a good idea
you should pay for sex and I don't
usually say that but save your money
we'll throw on a fund and I actually
believe that I work at the mill hey Mia
and cold hard cash we're just gonna pay
girls and hey I'm gonna pay you $200
today it's not a lot of money but you'll
be a regular customer so over the long
haul yeah make money with yes it's not
the home runs it's the singles that get
you some Hall of Fame I think
from that too yeah but maybe I don't
think it's gonna work for you so good
news message um me alone for the rest is
your awesome you're smart you're
handsome and the bad news is you're
hopeless now here's and also know here's
the thing you are having trouble with
this and and that's okay and the bad
news oh and uh that there's there's no
way to help you you're beyond help
and that no listen you'll figure it out
now find the girl and then or the girl
just has to have so much personality
she's just Chatty Cathy and yours
reacting to it sure you know I'm a solid
do you like a more dominate girl chin
that's the feeling I get
I quit dick I'm taking up the dick part
do you like you liked it
what what sign are you I'm Aries mmm
water sign okay I mean do you like a
more dominant female I like them both
ways all I can when they're shy and
nervous and cute and also when they're
like a real big personality everything
hmm yes it's on the same way I'm
probably like shy a lot and then really
loud you guys know [ __ ] aside chin
you're you're a catch you're you're
[Laughter]
you're a big guy you're very smart your
discipline you have a lot going on you
have a job yeah the car yeah there's
other guys dull so just know that okay
and and then stop me in a [ __ ] spaz
you know yeah it's not good it's gonna
be bad so we'll check in well check in
on Wednesday and I'm sure nothing on
Beijing can you guarantee us you'll have
the tinder profile by this week no no no
by Wednesday yeah you know my brother
even Jerry goes bro I I could do it
tinder profile in ten minutes
oh my god of course he couldn't but then
once you do that start swiping yes I
wanna make sure I want to make sure I'll
all set bro let's just give him the game
yeah you're after
hey this shows a priority so after
Wednesday's show I got nothing take a
picture of you right
be good and then I got Saturday bro
Wednesday chin make it happen all the
fans listen this blow up chin boom no I
like that see look at that they're
professional no maybe open your eyes up
I'm just kidding no no nope
we got it we got a we got a profile who
would crazy eyes but see that's a good
one there's your profile chin yeah all
right say to you Brian
God does what if I just use that boom i
chin I guarantee you you could put up a
picture of your [ __ ] and we're gonna
get crazy
smelly commas
I like that well that one looks like you
surprised yeah what a disaster alright
well I don't trust you look you're
looking at me like yeah it's like he's
looking at you waiting for you to take
your your eyes are off no look I belong
out of planting a goddamn bomb in the
White House we give them oh that's the
killer oh yeah that makes sense
well of course he lost his mind I like
this one Brian I do yeah good picture
looks like I'm just a nice guy yeah yeah
yeah you know I just may be your
chairman or program [ __ ] and upload that
Wednesday come on like they don't like
just faces I've been hearing you have to
have a whole box of em [ __ ] them I
guarantee you I'm gonna blast out
Brian's new bicep you have more chicken
heads knocking on your door you know
what to do all right I'll decide on the
picture today maybe though come on chin
can't wait for me yeah let's jump some
current events that's to it you guys
need a bathroom break you know I do got
a piss hole why do - let's go piss let's
go piss what do you got kid
all right this just came in Selena
Gomez's Instagram got hacked and the
first thing the hackers did was post
Justin Bieber's nude photos I guess she
still has him wait
i G hack yeah so she's stored is there
like private photos you keep an eye G uh
maybe in her oh yeah an app DMD okay
there you go there let's see ya wolf
this is all I saw
oh no that's fake sorry that's fake no
that's fake news that was on that was
from the hotel that's not real I think
those are the pictures we got from the
hotel I think that's just an example of
him being nude but this just came out
right now
so she immediately disabled her account
all day hon three property police
they'll be were flashing history with
death ahead look at this
ninja little shrimpy although the ledge
hackers include their IG handles and
claim they run the scene all right well
there's that little little shrimp I mean
even that pictures packin some very
small kid from when I was 17 maybes
grown alright so I saw this on Joe
Rogan's posts on Instagram so the New
York Times were an article about the
mayor the McGregor fight and they
described it you can see here McGregor's
face was completely bloodied he was
about to fall to the ropes and the
referee stopped the fight yes what's
wrong with New York Times I don't well
near ties has lost a lot of those old
boxing heads who are just like your
credibility they've done a lot of this
stuff but so uh real quick I'll show you
I looked at you know people started
writing articles about it because it was
completely fake he wasn't bloodied at
all you know so then I looked at who
wrote this paper is some guy named John
elegan do they have since corrected the
story right but they corrected in a
weird way so you saw that I said
bloodied face and then fell through the
ropes or was about to fall through the
ropes and in the story
they showed a correction after all this
is you know backlash the an earlier
version of this article says read yeah
and it was of an editing error an
earlier version startled miss stated the
maximum length of the UFC fight it so
they took out the bloodied and they took
out the rope part but they only said
that they corrected the bloody part it's
still kind of weird so I looked up the
sky the riders a young block dude and he
for the New York Times and his he's a
correspondent that covers race which I
felt was really weird yeah they have a
lot of people on their payroll so he
also does probably doesn't know he's
talking about to be honest did you look
at his background correspondent covering
for the New York Times two time family
few champion Detroit Pistons fan
Northwestern new alum proud trinny
Trinidad please yeah uh he just don't
know what he's talking about so when he
wrote that's probably trying to get
headlines yeah completely [ __ ] up
right even watch the fight right even
watch the fight saw the headlines blast
that out his tweet to fake news no it
was the article so he had to watch the
fight I mean maybe yeah you'd be
surprised or he just saw the highlights
and was like Oh bloodied and battered I
don't know what the [ __ ] I'm talking
about
strange well yeah that's gonna lean also
alright so the fight had about an
estimated 100 million illegal streams
100 million holy mother of god that must
have been places where they couldn't get
pay-per-view but no people knowledge ask
yeah a jacket but I mean imagine all
that money to how many people know it
was the number one fight for the first
time ever so available on more platforms
than any fight ever incredibly the
systems were shut down yeah everybody
watched that fight and everybody knew
about that fight
they couldn't even login to a hundred by
400 million viewers by far the biggest
fight of all yeah I didn't believe it
would be that's through just illegal I
remember you said that way back in the
day and I just don't know I was like I
don't write because I just didn't know I
didn't think that MMA and Conor McGregor
had that kind of a reach the little
trust me I thought it was just in
Ireland and you know but I was wrong I
was wrong about all of it that was
interesting what else you got
alright here's the story of a woman beat
the heck out of another woman because
one of them is apparently racist alright
okay so they're in a hotel log I'm not a
good idea that yeah racist tell me what
happened to so one woman is when you
hear the story when you're the names is
kind of trippy too so one woman was
talking bad about some Haitian guests in
a in a lobby oh yeah they're black yeah
yeah so then
this woman one woman says you know you
know she shouldn't say stuff like that
and the other one touched her and after
she touched her the other one went on
her so guess you white girls two white
girls oh let me also give you their
names one is Colleen dag and the other
ones summer quarts so if you look at
these two women who do you think is who
what once on a for getting the [ __ ]
Colleen dag is the one doing the [ __ ]
the DAGs is beating the [ __ ] and that
sound like an older woman's name to a
bit this is the one that beat up the
racist oh [ __ ]
Colleen day yeah I'll tell you right now
dag by stuck-up dad looks like she's no
stranger to the hey guy who dark me damn
that but that shot shooting your [ __ ]
thing up oh she's taking off her shoes
she beat the brakes off of her good idea
I will say that that the racist girl on
your face and you're gonna do that you
better be ready to fight him and dad
that fighting a quick whole wean DAGs
like you're in the UFC yeah her first
page fans there yeah this is a young
country built on racism black people
have been disseised for over 250 years
the faster white people accept and
validate the truth the closer will come
to a place of peace and understanding
fighting racism is dependent upon using
my white privilege for the right reasons
there were two examples of white
privilege in the video the woman the
blue dress tried to use her white
privilege on me the fact that I'm white
too must have slipped her mind if you
see it say something it's really that
simple
disclaimer some people can't handle the
truth stay ready [ __ ] white people there
is that there is that subset of white
people that are
I want to be more outraged at racism
than the actual people that it's being
perpetrated on so some of this gets a
little crazy I feel like she's the type
of white girl that hates white people
yeah there's a lot of white privilege
itself is that I talk about this my
stand-up now white privilege itself
gives me nowhere to go I when you say
that I don't know what you want me to do
like I should I suffer more like there's
a hole it's a whole thing man so I you
got to be careful with that hey Joe
it'sit's a yeah I'm gonna say yeah if
you're wrong kollene DAGs watch myself
watch yourself with that white privilege
it Kevin you are a goddamn white
privilege I'm not gonna get in her face
unless certain a few insult misses DAGs
look at me should be Jack give me a few
gun I'd love to take a beat-down from
her you would sure sorry sorry sorry
sorry
they sure have to call her masters um oh
well I don't think I will that why
Master I'm sorry
Master she's gonna whip you ah she's
putting her hands there like she wants
the resort put my hands on you you're
putting hands on me
yeah oh don't hit my but I perk my boss
Brian call you boy spent you can't beat
the racist out of anybody we know that
nope you can you can try to persuade and
change hearts and minds with XI tribes
yeah they had a program in Yemen of all
places where they had these young
radical Islamic met boys men and they
were the joining groups and things and
they had they would put them in front of
these these scholars these Islamic
scholars who were older men and
moderates and they would say I'll tell
you what give us your philosophy on life
and used Islam to justify it and we as
Islamic scholars will see if there's any
truth to it
and these guys would give them this way
I feel about Islam and they these the
scholarly intelligent erudite older men
would basically say that's your your
foundation for your fanaticism is wrong
and here's why and these guys were
Islamic scholars and it apparently and
this is from the New York Times pretty
liberal newspaper it had really great
results because these young men got D
radicalized because they were you know
killing or trying to kill people or
under the banner of Islam
they had these Islamic scholars who are
like you're not being his mama yeah
Tariq Aziz had the best idea I've heard
he said why don't we call Isis the
non-believers why are we calling them
Isis just call them non-believers when
you do that you take away take away the
Mormon I love you I'm sorry the Muslim
sure I love I love that kind of stuff
there are ways to PB people without
hands well thank you for holding my hand
you have a very heavy hand a strong hand
ah you got a strong ah
that's I can't all right let me get a
good grip really squeezing no cuz you
had me in the wrong position now now
what's up bro no don't try to get a good
who I can grip see that do it don't [ __ ]
bro bro don't [ __ ] it up Oh miss control
that I was a wrestler one thing about me
I ride risks heavy I'm a heavy wrist
rider I'm a dick diver but a heavy wrist
rider as well dick diver is while I'm
deep in your rump er you know that right
when you feel my balls and I'm working
you're [ __ ] rich and you feel my boss
my American balls slapping up against
your [ __ ] white privileged ass that's
what I do every time I push him so
emerging and then when I come it's like
this
and then you go oh oh I had to go what I
see what happens just what happened I'm
50 and you're just talking about some
Muslim research sorry guys see what
happens you and we started grabbing each
other no I just you know yeah that's
very uncomfortable by the way why no why
no one do you like fries no I guess Isis
no not white privilege use better idea
way to play without ideas yeah well
that's JJ although that girl deserves a
beatdown
sometimes people need a punch in the
face am i right she beats races
sometimes some people do need to get
punched in their [ __ ] face she's did
assault her first so yeah I wonder if
calling DAGs on instagram like whoa whoa
booty wah whoa whoa what's up white boy
wha whoa whoa all up here at chick flick
here he put me did you guys ever watch
Straight Outta Compton yeah sure look
like the guy that played eazy-e yeah he
was on an airplane and yes on Delta yeah
he kind of went a little hey easy actor
melts down on Delta in quotes where's my
first-class seat please play this using
King Kong
he's having a moment not the best way
it's so embarrassing what people say
when he's holding up everyone else see
that's probably her to be like bro I got
place to be - man this son he's got he's
gonna regret this I agree he's gonna
regret I'll be doing this yeah he's just
gonna regret this he's out of himself
he's my guy go spitting at the guy go
sit back there and call deltal tomorrow
let's take off man wait so he doesn't
have a seat he paid for first class they
didn't give him a seat he got yes so he
paid for first class and they thought
they said he said that they
double-booked him but Delta is saying
that he was on a standby because he
missed his first flight I can't miss
your first flight yeah yes that's on you
you paid for Delta another flight and
then you damn cross over the he's going
he's going he's gonna regret this this
is a Paris how's it end chin just to him
keep doing the same [ __ ] was he was
apologizing for keeping people waiting
but he was cussing out everyone else at
the same time and finally he just got
off he was [ __ ] you all sure when he
leaves it says foggy to everyone
I got much yep for the previous flight
yeah and there he's it yeah that's bad
news man that is not what not what would
I call classy what a mess
things aren't going well for him I mean
in his professional life it should be
good he's doing well he's booking a lot
of jobs but is he I feel like that would
try to I think he's an emotional guy he
[ __ ] knows man I don't know how's that
working Hollywood be well directors go
oh he's a hot air to really go [ __ ] I'd
be pissed dude it doesn't help
doesn't help right no watch that goes I
can relate to that
oh you know what they do is they go I'll
tell you what that does because you know
how a film when you're on a film you
can't wait right if there's millions of
dollars at stake and everybody it's
collaborative and everybody's a
profession but he gets along yeah and
when you have that you go what if he
does it on my set yeah oh boy and what
happens is this subtle they go is there
anybody else it's just I just worry what
would you do what would you do it's been
here a fair amount of it's between him
and another guy equally talented I try
to go the other guy why because I don't
know this yeah what does that there he's
gonna do it when something doesn't go
right [ __ ] must be so frustrating of
course it is but you missed your first
flight bro
yeah that's on you you missed your first
flight you can't I got [ __ ] to do all
souls everyone here also Cibola back you
to everybody
I like that that's just not cool but
also that's ghetto [ __ ] get your
seat get your seat that you know what I
mean that's bad that's that's class I'll
see what do you have to do as never do
with first class you getting home you
can still get home on time we now you're
delaying the flight so what's more
important you getting home Jeff [ __ ] to
do or sit in first class to your social
status yeah bad news
well you miss yellow no this is Tara
Compton [ __ ] sit down mmm-hmm he was it
[ __ ] you you sit down [ __ ] and easy
you ain't the real easy that's what I
said that's the same two movies [ __ ]
yep I'll just give you on [ __ ]
Delta team Delta yeah we dealt a [ __ ]
yeah
we dealt a little [ __ ] you know beer
about the [ __ ] you like sugar
and I'm serious as they sit back here be
up I'm serious is a tease get the [ __ ]
off the plane they're saying cuz he died
of a you get yep
it's good yeah I'm a serious is every
time an echo it [ __ ]
yep little [ __ ] you [ __ ] let's do
[ __ ] belch black [ __ ] look see how I
we're quiet see well I was testing your
racism there okay because that's what
someone white privilege would do on that
plane right then I would then see then
we gonna fight white print I don't get
down with either this this whole notion
it gives nobody yeah tell Russians that
their their privilege their 20s it's
unsanitary tell the dude who's whose
were who worked in a steel mill has no
job in he's on opiates if he's white
privilege cracks me up
it's not very helpful for the discussion
just breaks privilege just breaks people
in the team so yeah I am bronze white
pros alright in China they're ordering
internet comments to be linked to the
actual people that are commenting oh so
no more trolls so that well it's mainly
for their governments or dogs natural
they they know your ass [ __ ] come and
pay you a visit
yeah they're great it's not a breeder
level yeah they're not big on freedom
they are big on government control
within major Dobis electronics the best
electronics hey for sure come up with my
phone eight China because my cell phone
is broke and I hit you for an upgrade
and I'm waiting for that eight I need an
upgrade to I think I've the spider-man
edition my cell phone is cracked like a
[ __ ] and I'm waiting for that
new one to come out you ain't get my
$200 to fix that screen hell no hell no
not I've been here [ __ ] I paid my money
white proves [ __ ] you [ __ ] and I don't
want that white iPhone I want the black
one goes boom white lady white privilige
[ __ ] get off the phone with white lady
what if I say cut off the phone black
lady raised ass races
yeah we got it we live in a double
standard I'm sick of it now what if you
say just the phone Asian it's all we're
all very sensitive and it's not full
white boy yeah if you're white you're
already guilty nowadays you know you
have to fold Hawaiian yeah get off the
phone Mexican there's this that's right
your honor ogen was saying something
really I'm saying it like this
whole subset of the sort of left-wing
that is there professionally offended
and that's part of their identity
they're offended by everything that's
defended my sensibilities are offended
I'm offended by everything everything's
racist and it's like mm okay dude that's
your that's part of your identity we
don't see that Jenna where you [ __ ]
um how about this Manny Pacquiao's tweet
to Floyd Mayweather after he won so
Floyd Mayweather tweets talking doesn't
win fights and then Pacquiao wrote but
running does I think God bless your
fight tonight or this one before God it
only got a hundred didn't run down hey
it only got a hundred retweets um yeah
yeah hey Manny just go away
yeah if we go away you stole our money
you fought with one arm you were hurt
you knew should've been fighting you
want the payday and you just lost to
that random Australian horn and you
gotta fight him we can go away though
it's over it's over man well you know I
love Manny Pacquiao and he can tweet
something it's fine yeah but also yeah
is it over for him
uh well just shows you his demand 100
retweets that was on the 26th uh so they
probably just took a picture that one
Manny Pacquiao fights crime goes down so
used to not anymore
his horn fight it's not the same oh yeah
again yeah I like me mommies fighting
but I thought you actually let's take a
look at [ __ ] in Houston in time and
Houston loaded I perform we're there LA
Times yep and driven around that place
that is that is astonishing that a Stu
highway and you know it's crazy today
they're saying the rains only get worse
you have to go for sale yeah I guess the
streets have always flooded in Houston
but this is like look at that [ __ ]
hot look how deep that is yeah look at
the height of this the cars over here it
sees completely engulfed that's a lake
it's a [ __ ] lake user load this is
the great flood
you know Noah where's Noah and what do
you do you build an ark you build an art
have a boat and you hang out for real
like you get a you get an awesome boat
that has done self-sufficient money yeah
it's fun you get a yacht or do you ever
see those bring up those do you bring up
those life boats that are
on big ocean liners they're
self-contained there yeah they're
they're built for storms and everything
they're kind of amazing they're really
cool and they're for sale too covered to
some of them like that right there that
thing that things really live on that
thing they'll be no but - Wow it's for a
while stay on that boat and I doubt
first of all those are super expensive I
doubt those I've been expanding on
Houston they're all gonna have these
boats yeah terrible idea I would have
one or a canoe look at those yeah those
are the things from captain Phillips I'm
your captain now and then you get
[ __ ] tortured yeah I don't know
Tara idea those are really expensive oh
that one's cool oh that's cool let me
see that one yeah yeah family of six
farting up in there
that's a tent yeah you know hot the
thing to me a muggy yeah it's gonna
engine you and your whole family in
there it's also gonna be tossed around
like a go for smell like a [ __ ] how you
doin the waves and that thing you're
gonna get [ __ ] tossed around
well it's got Jim whatever idea but I
think that's it it's all right Oh white
privilege knowledge worse I got a little
uh I got a little dropping knowledge for
us if I can [ __ ] just remember it no
uh you've heard me talk about this
before but yesterday or I think it was
David for Trump's signed the transgender
ban yeah military I think is gonna be
challenged in court i I just wanted to
UM listen I want to ask a question I'm
not here to drop I'm not here to really
make so much of a point of view I don't
know what it's like to lead men into
battle and I don't know much about the
transgender thing I just don't you know
Kristin back I know Kristin Beck my
instinct is always to sort of err on the
side of fair play and sort of my general
yeah yeah I tend to be a softy in that
in that regard and I think you know I
don't know why I would say soft there's
a Lawrence um I'm ignorant in many ways
about
you know both you've even been a man of
the night with a chick with a dick in a
man of the night with yes but I'm but
I'm still kind of ignorant too
I don't know anything about military
strategy what it's like to run the
military but I do think that when you
exclude people because they think and
talk and look and act and love
differently you better be careful about
that because people like that can be
very creative and I've said this before
but I think it's worth talking about
again you know part of what makes our
country great is that we have different
definitions of what strength is strength
is not just big muscles it's not just
being able to deal and kill a bunch of
people it sausage it's also about being
creative and innovative and being a deep
and bilateral or a lateral thinker you
know somebody who can think outside the
box and those people a lot of times are
not what on the surface look strong they
might even be weirdos but they have
strong minds and therefore strong minds
like I do this joke where I could
probably if you put David Bowie Prince
Lady Gaga
Einstein Stephen Hawking and throw
Gandhi in there as well I could probably
beat all of them up at the same [ __ ]
time but it doesn't mean I want to live
in a world without them and it certainly
doesn't mean that I'm stronger than
their so we should probably take into
account the fact that this country is
great because we have a lot of different
definitions of what strengths are and
more importantly we give that strength
expression we protect our gentler
spirits and our our people that are
different and we have to because they
come up with the ideas that make our
world a better place how many military
tactician x' or even people who have
something to offer our national security
our transgender maybe none maybe some i
don't know the answer I'd rather err on
the side of caution and it bums me out
that word this exclusive well you know
both will you're beholding your side
doing 15 just realize that as you said
that bums me out looking of a holy [ __ ]
but he knows how I'm wearing my little
anklets now yeah yeah so please think
about that ladies and gentlemen try to
be fair mind your harrassing me
don't hair it up on the military and you
don't grab my tits I know you tell you
that night don't put your hands to my
tits bro I don't know you to do that you
bully be where you gonna be
I'm glad you asked buddy I'm gonna be
out a couple places dick diving mmm mmm
be and if you're transgender come on by
dick taboo which is the blue which is
the the huge music festivals down in Del
Mar September 15th the 21st 22nd 23rd
I'm gonna be in Madison Wisconsin can't
wait bring yo cheese oh yeah
calm down state and then on in I'll be
in Philly the 28th 29th 30th so come on
and down at helium I'll be there in
Philly so come on
I love down oh it's gonna be good now
now I want to just I want to just talk
about something cuz I know where you're
gonna be huh I'm already blood red mad
this [ __ ] guy Eugene you're not the
king the guy's got he's coming to Cobbs
first of all I'm already furious cities
and Cobbs for one night only doing
comedy a car sold out this [ __ ]
you sold all right oh yeah it's like 23
it's let you look happy bro graphic no
you look sweet but I figure him as a
king as a king on the iron gamerdomey
King Comedy some other [ __ ] who came
Karenina
on common calves I'm coming yeah I'm
human me Lords if you guys go to his
comedy before I get to cause I want you
to delete I stop following me hope
you're not my fan all right that's all I
have to say cops I'll be a cop September
14th one night only they might do a
second show less than 20 tickets left go
to tea frat K calm right now hopefully
they had a second show without is
September 14th Cobb's comedy club San
Francisco and then I'm in Long Beach on
the 22nd of September at
laughs factory Long Beach laughs after
both shows almost sold out t fat K comm
hit it this is a firing kid we're out